southend we live cycling club is open to
cyclists of all abilities and ages there
are regular social and training rights
on and off-road rides Youth coaching and
social events training and social rider
take place every sunday meeting at
commuting village hall at ten a.m. for
more information visit www saw rockford
hundred rugby football club meet at the
clubhouse Magnolia road SS or three ad
matches on Saturdays and Sundays
training during the week family
orientated rugby club with teams for
everyone from under sixes upwards with
coaching and team management for each
side contact zero 17025 double 4021
Rochford disability football academy
meets at cedar hall school heart road SS
73 you you'll that's in thundersley
adults 11am tool known youth known to
1pm each saturday coaching and
competitive opportunities for young
people and adults with special
participation needs contact 0170 2207
217 westwood karate academy meet at
raley Leisure Centre every Wednesday 6pm
to 7pm for children 7pm to 8pm for
adults and sundays 10 a.m. to 11am for
children they also mated clements hall
edge ascend to every friday 7 32 8 30
for children and adults and sundays
1130-1230 for children and adults
catering for adults and children of all
ages from four years and the first four
weeks are absolutely free contact 0 1
702 double 5980 for watch the bowls club
when the season runners october to march
the indoor short mat bowls club play
internal leagues internal and external
competitions friendly matches and
organized social events players of all
ages and abilities are welcome
contact 0170 223 00 28 Bailey leisure
indoor bowls club means at Raley Leisure
Centre Priory chase SS 69 n F new or
existing bowlers of all ages or ability
welcome the four rink facility is
available at any time the leisure center
is open coaching is available for anyone
wishing to try out the sport prior to
joining the club contact 01 2687 807
double eight Fitz why mark badminton
club meet in the David Cox sports hall
the Fitz while Mark school hockey road
club night on tuesday evening is open to
members and invited guests from 732 to
10pm use coaching for 12 to 16 year old
is on tuesday and friday evenings 6pm to
730 p.m. the club has a home venue of
five quarts and is always on the lookout
for new players contact 01 268 double
seven 1914
the south end Hospital public meetings
find out more about the hospital at
public meetings around south east essex
there will be clinical presentations on
subjects such as arthritis prostate
cancer HRT and heart pacemakers after
which the chief executive will talk
about the hospital's plans for the
future the next meeting will be
wednesday the 25th of january at 115
p.m. it'll be at the yacht club at
brandy whole paul's lane hullbridge SS
56 QB everyone's welcome including
children and to ensure that adequate
refreshments are available please call
the free phone number zero eight-hundred
0 1 8520 to or email foundation members
at Southend NHS UK to confirm your
attendance clubs and societies the roach
art group meets on Wednesday evenings
between seven-thirty and 930 absence
Teresa's church hall ashington road
rochford that's just at the rear of the
church beginners are especially welcome
but all abilities are catered for this
friendly club who work in a variety of
media at a venue with good lighting and
facilities reasonable fees apply details
on request contact christine on 0 1 702
586 336 or John on 0793 3263 930 there's
an art class with Paul all clock on
Tuesday afternoons 1pm to 3pm that the
Women's Institute Hall bellingham Lane
rayleigh learn to paint and draw using
your favorite mediums beginners and
experienced students are welcome contact
0170 2615 475 or email paul and read at
sky.com for further details the cost is
six power
session Rayleigh Age Concern meet at the
Todman Center in Castle Road rayleigh
five days a week 52 weeks a year between
ten-thirty a.m. & 2pm rayleigh age
concern is eager for more older people
to attend and enjoy its daily lunch and
Club home cooked fresh food made on the
premises is provided transport to and
from the venue can also be arranged for
a moderate cost entertainment and social
events are regularly arranged contact 01
268 double 75 380
community center stanbridge Memorial
Hall will be available from January 2012
for anyone to hire morning afternoon and
or evening sessions and it will be open
seven days a week for more information
or booking us please contact the clock
to stanbridge Parish Council on 0170 to
double 55 347 or stanbridge PC at faiths
team co uk rayleigh markets rayleigh
market is relocating to the taxi rank
from wednesday the seventh of december
between 8am and 2pm the taxi pickup
point will be at the label i near the
clock and the taxi drop off point at the
lay-by near the crown pub local sporting
memories wanted marla wynne bill is now
a nationally accredited visitor
attraction and houses an exhibition
space on the second floor the windmill
is open from april to September and
attracts thousands of visitors every
year in the past few years the windmill
exhibition floor has displayed many
exhibitions of local groups from gold
guides and local artists to local
history groups once again the council
would like to invite local community
groups to come forward to promote the
work of their group and the
opportunities to participate next season
the council's leisure services team
would like to include a sports theme as
we look forward two hundred twenty
twelve to celebrate this we are
especially interested in hearing from
local sports clubs that were going to
get involved in our exhibition showing
the history of local sporting life does
your club have old pictures or trophies
showing success through the years
perhaps your club has other old
memorabilia so placing its history if
this sounds like your club then we want
to hear from you if you are interested
in exhibiting at the windmill please
contact the leisure team on 0170 25 463
double six or email leisure at Rochford
gov dot uk'
and now we have some council committee
dates for you the meetings are all at
the Civic sweet in rayleigh at
seven-thirty p.m. the review committee
on the tenth of january 2012 the
executive committee on the eleventh of
january development committee 26th of
january council meeting 30 first of
January review committee seventh of
februari executive eighth of februari
council meeting 21st of februari
development committee 23rd of februari
council again 28 of februari review
committee sixth of march west community
forum 13th of march executive 14th of
March audit committee 27th of March
development committee 29th of March
review committee third of April
executive fourth of April standards
committee twelfth of April Council 17th
of April development committee 19th of
april and there's one meeting that will
be held at the lecture theatre hawthorne
center rochford hospital Union Lane
roxford SS or one RB that will be on the
twentieth of March 2012 at 7pm and
that's the East community forum for more
information contact member services on 0
1 702 318 140
a Christmas message from the chairman
being chairman of the council has been a
much bigger experience than I could ever
have imagined it has been amazing to
meet so many people who give up so much
time and energy to help and support
other people to meet people whose only
motive for doing what they do is knowing
that it's the right thing to do has been
truly humbling and it really is quite an
eye-opener to learn that there are so
many groups clubs and organizations
working away in all areas of our
community I have been particularly keen
to give opportunities for the talents of
our secondary school pupils to be
showcased at events I can assure you
that there is a wealth of talent and
skill in that group of young people that
should make us all feel very confident
about the future my fiance packed and I
have really enjoyed all our visits so
far this year if i can help in
supporting any activity that you're
organising then please let me know we
have been working hard to share our
experiences as we go out and about other
parts of essence we have certainly
noticed that visitors to our district
are very complimentary and indeed quite
envious of the district's natural beauty
facilities wonderful sense of community
and support that we offer to one another
in October we celebrated our sports
personalities of the year and look
forward to celebrating a special citizen
of the year in 2012 if you know an
unsung hero please let me know Christmas
is now almost with us I do hope that you
are all able to enjoy a very merry
christmas and a happy new year simon
smith counselor simon smith of german of
the watch the district council these are
some of the examples of the Chairman's
visits foul ness by tried chairman simon
smith was invited by the rotary club of
thought way to start the cyclists
alongside the mayor of South End
councillor David Norman for the foul
nest bike ride to raise money for the
southend-on-sea station of the Royal
National Lifeboat institution the
chairman and his fiancee Pat decided to
sign up and participate in the fun of
the 23 mile trip
poster competition the Chairman makes
grace crook from Edward Francis junior
school to congratulate her for winning
her poster competition organized by
watch the District Council the
competition was to design a poster to
promote the benefits of healthy eating
and not smoking and helped raise levels
of awareness of the issues for young
people rochford allotments the rockford
allotments and leisure gardeners
association invited the chairman to
their second annual show to officially
open their flower and arts and crafts
show hull breach green gym the Chairman
was pleased to accept an invitation from
whole bridge Parish Council to their
official opening of the green gym at
palms rain recreation ground helping the
chairman try out the equipment is essex
county councillor if Elizabeth heart and
councillor Anjali in a Marriott chairman
of hullbridge Parish Council